i've known this guy for quite some time
our our our children used to go to
school together
that's how long it's been since uh i've
known him and um
i love his work phenomenal um stuff from
this man who's an ap bio by the way
uh right here on peacock we can also
mention that amongst many items
including
his live virtual comedy show patton
oswalt arms length patton oswalt here on
the show how you been patting
i'm doing great rich how you doing man
i'm doing fine did we ever
did we ever um handle parking and
traffic together in front of the uh
nursery school together do we ever
do that once upon a time i seem to think
that we might have
put on those the orange slicker tuesdays
and then although i may have filled in a
few times i feel like
i know that tuesdays was was my day to
go in and direct and
you know move cars just wave people in
and wave people off and
yep yeah and you got to be that guy
sometimes
with uh with parents move things along
don't leave your car running without
your keys in there and it was
it got dicey patton i got to be honest
with you guys
it got a little dicey and it also got it
was it was a weird lesson and
wow i could actually slide pretty
quickly into fascism
no that is not how we do this you've
been here three weeks you already know
this there's no excuse like
because i would get you know there's
kids walking along and people were like
rushing into the driveway and almost
hitting people
right i would get really really like
wound up about it i would get really
angry
well if all you need to do is just give
me one orange vest slicker
to make me feel like i'm in charge you
know
and i just become a different person you
know it's like
well it was really it was really weird
how you would put that on and go well
you know i do have authority here
i do as a matter of fact you need to
move your car up two inches i'm gonna be
that guy
you know like i did that i just have a
memory that i think i did it with you
once
at any rate uh we been there done that
uh
essentially oh boy been there done that
yeah uh what have you been up to in the
pandemic sir other than just doing a ton
of work but uh have you just been
hanging out what have you uh what have
you been up to sir
it's such a weird isn't that a weird
question i know that now
we're cause you we all know in a way a
version of what we're doing i'm i'm
home trying to stay active learning i
mean we all had to
i'm sure you had to very um quickly
scramble to learn how to be your own
engineer
lighting guy sound guy like yes have to
do everything
in your home basically yes now you are a
you you are a mobile production facility
yes sir right not by choice
by necessity yes sir just give me a
light and a laptop and i can make magic
patton that's all i need is a light in
the laptop
i'm telling you i spent all day
yesterday i got a new set of ring lights
and a new
microphone and i was so excited it was
sad it was
i've become you know what this is how
like old people tell stories about their
lives
when they get to the world where like a
trip to the cvs is exciting and you
actually want to tell someone about it
and if they're like i don't care that
you want to see it no but but i left my
house
i was in the car and i drove and you
know
when i put the it's like yeah you're
just excited to be outside
you haven't been outside exactly exactly
but what about
uh flipping around on uh tv throughout
this time
uh being indoors and seeing and seeing
something that you forgot you were in
is there anything that's happened to you
yeah that
wait a minute when did that happen oh
they were showing um
a movie one night called observe and
report it's a seth rogen movie
okay and i forgot that i was the toaster
gun manager and he shoves my head into a
toaster oven
at one point in the movie which was
because like how did i forget that seth
roach and shove my head into a toaster
i don't remember that that's a good
question that's a very good question
you'd think you would remember something
like that i don't i don't wouldn't that
burn itself into my head
i know that is something else but also i
guess in this time and age i've become
uh
because of uh you know sports and
whether a game's going to be on or not
i've
i've kind of become a a practicing
epidemiologist
trying to learn all this stuff you know
i i i never thought i would have to know
about public health
uh you know to talk about whether you
know a game's happening or not
so i'm gonna ask you something because i
don't know i don't have a perspective on
this i'm not
i don't really follow sports yes sir but
obviously
they started playing baseball again and
i guess they've started playing
they played a season of nba basketball
yes they did they bubbled up and disney
world
actually patton they've sent they sent a
whole bunch of people to disney world
but what was it like for you as a sports
fan watching
games and its empty stands or cutouts
like did that affect your watching it
was it a different experience
no no because it you know what it was
weird it was weird to start
to be very honest with you it was a
little bit it was a little weird to
start
but once you realize that the athletes
themselves were treating it
with the professionalism and the
competitive value
um that that that was normal that
uh i lost myself i didn't i didn't think
about it i really didn't
i really didn't think about it it was
just you know i i was just thrilled to
have it
again you know to between i guess you
know
march and may or march and june doing a
show like this every single day
when you don't know if sports are going
to return and you're talking about
what's going on
in the real world um more than what
people
would expect from a show like this it
was uh it was
unique let's put it that way you know it
also must have felt weird because you're
like
hey guys i'm sorry if you're tuning in i
know i'm supposed to be your escape from
the real world
but none of us can escape it right now
so i kind of have to talk about it right
i
wish i could give you some i wish we
could argue about this new running back
that everyone thinks is overrated and i
can take calls we could scream at each
other but
that's just not happening i'm gonna try
my best right i don't know what to do
that was accurate except for the part
about the screaming i like to just have
normal
uh nuanced conversation patton you know
what i mean like i'd like to just
you know i mean like at least that's the
way i i could at least put my head on
the pillow at night
although there are some other people in
my industry that would think differently
i don't know
um so you know what show i discovered
during this and
i'm late to this show by the way i
discovered it two weeks ago blew through
it
is that show on apple tv called um ted
lasso
oh god how great is that with sudaikus
right
it is i again i am so blown away
by it is the simplest premise and the
premise
when you see it oh he's a good old boy
who comes to england to coach soccer
you're like
okay i can think of maybe five jokes for
that right that'll that's all it's gonna
be
and it is the deepest funniest
like that they take what seems to be
this premise shouldn't work or it should
get boring immediately
and it's one of the best shows i've ever
seen i've ever seen
i've heard the same thing uh my wife and
i we're uh we're currently binging
shit's creek
right now we're trying to get through it
oh well our children don't go to sleep
on time and we're
wiped out and if we can watch one or two
of them where we're we're lucky
but i ted last year might have to be
next once we're through all that
you know oh as a sp you uh oh i'm you
i'm really jealous that you're gonna get
to watch ted lasso for the first time
okay
like that's one of those shows that when
you recommend it someone they go oh i
haven't seen it yet
you you don't go how is it you just go
i'm so
jealous you're going to get to see it i
wish i could erase it for my brain to
watch it again
kidding how about that it's it's that
and again you're gonna watch the
beginning and go well this
there's no way this can sustain it's
like five jokes and then you realize oh
no
this is about so much more
well i guess then we should also i'm not
going to i don't know but it's good
to use i guess the again i've been using
this phrase a lot i've seen it from all
the cnn anchors these days
we'll just leave it there that's how
they that's how they finish
conversations we'll just have to leave
it there
um so let's talk about i i mentioned uh
the website
on locationlive.com patton oswalt
to see your virtual comedy show um
pat and oswald arms length i get that
that information is correct right
i got that that is correct that is this
friday six o'clock pacific
nine o'clock eastern uh go there get a
ticket an hour of new material
and so basically you're going to be in
your in your
your home and just talking doing your
your stand-up act and
how does this work how's it happening
i'm going to be sitting in a very
well-lit kitchen
very nice because it has the best
acoustics of all places
and i'm just going to be talking about
the world so you're not kidding when you
got a new microphone and a new system
that you were genuinely pumped
up like this is this is actually
important for your
gift this is a this is an exciting
moment in my last six months this is a
this is definitely a highlight of my
life these last six months i got a new
microphone
and light okay so tune in tune in just
to hear my new mic
and my new lights okay on
locationlive.com and i was mentioning as
well since we're on peacock that ap bio
thanks to peacock is uh
is still alive patton yes they gave us a
third season god bless them
they let us do the best stuff on that
show and still streaming and
i just i just watched the um uh the
katie holmes day episode yesterday it's
brilliant now um do you want to put a
little bit more meat on that bone right
there for everybody
um out there well again there's so many
basically they
the writers thought of this idea for the
episode there's an episode where
the town of toledo celebrates katie
holmes day because katie holmes
came from toledo and it's this whole
elaborate holiday that
the town that the writers made up that
the town like goes to and it almost
feels like a real thing
where they celebrate her career and her
life and um
it's it's um there's so many surprises
and
of course jack glenn howerton the start
of the show um
hates the idea of katie holmes day is
just now finding out about it and then
like the grinch he tries to destroy it
um but they just work so many amazing
variations on on the grinch that stole
christmas
and the idea of what a holiday is and of
course
everything that you need to know about
katie holmes it's pretty brilliant
well as we know katie holmes just makes
your heart grow larger
i guess to continue on with that grinch
exactly at the very end of the day
oh rich thanks that's the meaning of
katie holmes
i nailed it i nailed it i stuck the
landing uh at pat
oswalt on twitter and instagram follow
him i do uh it's a great follow with you
patton
and um and let's you you are most
welcome thanks for the call let's do
this again
real soon that's so sweet thanks man say
hello to the lovely wife
i will do that and i hope you guys are
keeping safe okay right back at you
thanks for the call brother that's uh
pat
oswald patton oswalt on twitter and
instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here